[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the uh
popular host of the dan levitard show
he's got a
big 24-hour marathon coming up that's
some programming going on there he's uh
dan levitar who joins us now is this a
telethon are you raising money for
charity what are you doing yeah we are
but can i if i may
dan because you're such a kind
professional and a legitimately good
friend to me i want to say some things
here and like weave a tapestry of
gratitude for
uh the guys who work with you and for
the audience
uh i'd like to do that if you would uh
give me a moment but before i do
that i have to point out to you because
you're such a professional that we can
move smoothly through these things
you're having me follow and you handled
it well sending a bag of swag
but i'm coming into like one of the
biggest moments of my life today
and you're having me follow what was a
heartbreaking telephone call
and now i'm i got to come out here and
do jazz hands and and be wacky
and uh and that was that was hard to
listen to you handled that very
gracefully it feels like that would that
could have been very awkward
well you also have to follow coach k and
that's
tough too so i'm just just saying that
okay well there's this
okay and this is where i went ahead with
this because yes he just hit me in the
face with the fish if i've got
coach k today hey big 24 hour boy uh
yeah
i got coach k today what do you got he
was just on here a second ago i want to
i want to weave this genuine sincere
uh tapestry of gratitude about the man
that is sitting in front of you right
now
because when he talks about the emmys
with a smirk on his face as a pioneer in
this industry as somebody who has been
like an
anchor of professionalism as america has
changed and sports coverage has changed
and he's in the middle of it
fair and stoic delivering you a great
radio program that i'm sitting here on
here today to talk about our big 24-hour
extravaganza this starts at noon
and he just said to you that's our
tuesday we got
that coming up next tuesday at my house
when we lose the enemies and make fun of
ourselves we've got a bunch of good
guests so dan patrick has been doing
across
now you know many many years the kind of
work
that um that deserves uh not just these
prizes that we give these silly these
silly trophies but
uh in terms of sharing this space with
me in terms of you specifically being a
human being when he says he's
competitive
people he will eat your grandmother's
knee
to beat her by an inch on something like
he is
an insane person when it comes to
competitive and yet
all he did with me as i was coming up is
share his platform with me teach me how
to share that platform
teach me how to take care of a family of
employees who he genuinely loves
and i just want everyone in this
audience to know that that competitive
man never made it feel
like we were competing against each
other in this business of vanity and
insecurity and nonsense
that's an uncommon grace and so i am
here to bestow upon you dan patrick
right now uh more than that bum dan
please act
you are the greatest of the dans you
will win a danny you win
among you and me you have been a pioneer
and a teacher and you've given our crew
permission to do the show
the way that you did it first and so i
am genuinely thankful that you are
here uh again sharing your stage with me
i'm sorry if i made that sappy
can we use what levitar just said for
next year's emmys
yes because that to me would go a long
way that levitard is endorsing me
because by then he's going to be huge
like he's big in the business and this
whole
partnership and meadowlark meadowlark
lemon
and like it's pretty incredible what uh
dan's done
a 24-hour marathon of uh programming
and you got big names you got jim rome
you got you got jim rome
uh yes okay all right
jim rome why did you say it like that i
don't understand why you said it like
that
well this is the press release and the
first name
um an eclectic buffet featuring
the likes of jim rome bob costas
and michelle beadle that that's what it
says
so i just i'm just taking what's here
there are other names there too though
for some reason you specifically i feel
like you specifically chose jim rome
first when
that you know pat riley is on there
method man is on there pat
sajak is on there we've got a whole
bunch of surprise
appearances and the first one you went
to for some reason i wasn't clear on
and there was a there i may be wrong on
this but there felt like there was some
acid
on your spit was jim rome what colin
cowherd uh not available
like roy firestone uh
jt the brick yeah
we almost did a duet there
jt the brick is on the marquee you know
fran
francesa and russo you couldn't you know
reunite them
do people understand dan that as a
television person you reinvented
yourself
to change this game too as you mentioned
these other colleagues of our that are
titans of industry
but like do people understand who have
been with you and call you uncle dan
because you're
you're in their house and that's the
connection this space makes like uh
you should be pretty proud of yourself
on this stuff i know i keep doing that
to you but like
i i really want your audience to
understand what a caring human being
this is under all the
television foofery wiring that he has to
have because he's super poised
legend man and he can do game shows and
he's always stoic and never sweats
and he's just perfect at television i
want you guys to know that
in there that dude right there changed
this game
came into radio that wasn't his place
came into radio and his producers were
talking on air
and his producers were you know doing
confessionals in a booth
and anything that we're doing today like
the spirit of it started with the better
dan
you know what's amazing and and dan
thank you for those kind words but you
know they don't mean anything to me
because
that's just too much as
i as i timed that while you were taking
a drink there
that yeah they don't mean anything thank
you dan thank you
great gratitude but i have to go back to
my emotional repressions i cannot ever
be good enough i have i must be better i
am television man
but you know my audience is very smart
and they're probably going
well dan levitard has a 24-hour marathon
of
programming he's got jim rome
he's got bob costas he's got michelle
beadle well obviously he's got dan
patrick because
he thinks so much of dan patrick there
we go
and i checked that paulie check the
poster because i
i don't think my name's on i've got the
poster right here okay
just do you see me it's real small at
the bottom but i still don't see you
okay
well look i gotta be there scott
pharrell oh yeah
you dirty rat you dirty rat he's been
setting this
joke up for three days he set me up dan
patrick set me up
you set yourself up you didn't even you
you forgot about me
i was gonna make your name did it you
forgot about me
i was gonna make your name bigger than
rome's i was and you told me you better
not put me on that poster and i'm like
no but your name can be in bigger
letters you can have the biggest media
letters
and he's like you better not setting me
up for this joke you're a
dirty dirty rat and you know what i i
said
i will not be your seat filler dan
levitard
don't even try that
jim rome was not at my wedding colin
cowherd was not bobcat
exactly and there and they're invited
they
passed to go to your wedding it was a
first draft of the movie poster
it was a first draft so you're on the
air for 24 hours
actually it's not a movie poster it's a
marquee it's a music festival marquee
and yes it's a festival
of freedom dan and it covers a lot of uh
ground here because you know some of my
story right my parents
cuban exiles freedom has been very
important to me
another place where you gave us
permission you left espn the worldwide
leader in sports you can't nobody leaves
that place you can't leave that place
and make a success of yourself you got
to stay there
that's the finish line that's the
destination dan patrick uh
carved the path for me uh you know
blazed it look no you can do this
this can be done this is something that
can be done outside of that and so here
we go
uh we went into free agency we got a big
digital monster of a thing people really
like our show in a way that's super
sticky right you and i have
rare radio audiences where the people
who love you
are super devoted to you in the way that
you heard in that phone call
you know of somebody who was grieving
and the laughter of this show was
medicine
to that person like there aren't many
audiences like that especially not now
in the argument culture
so uh what we have on youtube and you
could subscribe
levitard and friends is basically what
dan described to you he's doing
tuesday night at his house right they're
gonna just have these guys are gonna
gather around with their friends and
they're going to
you know make fun of losing the emmys
and you're going to be able to see parts
of it and
it's groundbreaking you're you're like
hanging with your friends if you're a
person lonely going through a dark time
like these these are in such an intimate
space this
group this family right here the defunct
dysfunctional family you've seen here
grow up among these guys into men from
from kids to adults if you've been
watching this show long enough
um they're showing you their lives on
tuesday and you can watch it and sort of
be with them
in the intimate audio space of your head
and so
we're just having a huge party dan for
24 hours where
a whole bunch of our friends like you
hopefully if you're still not mad at me
because your name wasn't
on the movie poster uh i will just swing
by and
you know make us laugh and and just and
people will be excited to see them
because dan they've been
they've been seeing you for 30 years
like they they recognize
they know television does not show you
real people okay not the way dan was
doing it a long time ago when he was
breaking the mold
on pioneering how to do sportscenter
with a smirk but
this dude right here like sitting in
front of you now like this is not how
that's done anymore dan
like you uh you should feel really good
about the uh the path that you blazed on
this because
your spirit is going to be within it
it's like you created a family
a family business and and it you know it
makes you as happy as you could be if
anything was good enough
uh and i have a family business and i'm
putting it on youtube for 24 hours
beginning at uh
you know in an hour and it's going to be
fun
and i'm going to enjoy the hell out of
it it's not going to be hard for us dan
because you you and i have had this
conversation before it's hard to do
these things
talk and say interesting things for a
long time but with the crew of people
that we've got here i've got enough
friends that they're going to make it a
rollicking thing that will vibrate
and uh i'd love i i've invited you to be
a part of it obviously and any of your
audience that cares to join
i think it's going to be a fun
experience but know that this man
offers me this platform the platform he
built that he pioneered
in order for me to tell you hey come
watch us because we're not competitors
we're friends and we're friends and that
will not that that
will not end like this business did not
break that this dude led the way for me
uh good luck with this and uh maybe i'll
maybe i'll talk to you tomorrow
but uh love you buddy thanks for coming
on thank you for real
love you dan i want everyone to know
that all right i'm sorry if i made it
awkward
that's dan levitard it's a 24-hour
marathon of all of his friends
except for me and that starts in an hour
from now